tomorrow at 10 o'clock p.m. we're gonna
air our next prime time travel special
you know I love to travel around the
world and tape these specials our next
one airs tomorrow night Conan in Ghana I
went to Ghana fantastic very proud of
this show that's right I've never been
to Africa before so we went to Ghana and
when I arrived in the capital city Accra
I hit the streets to meet the people and
find out what's going on there's a
little taste
no no passion for it for me no no what's
that
crudo get get a lot of passion if I eat
the passion fruits my wife will be happy
because I'll have the energy no be good
for me
[Applause]
yeah that was an error I apologize
anyway I had an amazing time the people
of Ghana are absolutely wonderful and I
brought along a friend with roots in
Ghana one of the hilarious stars of
HBO's veep mr. Sam Richardson came with
me and wonderful person to have along in
the trip so be sure to tune in for our
Conan in Ghana special it airs tomorrow
that's tomorrow November 7th at 10 p.m.
make sure you check it out
[Applause]